nos dicen esta tabla muestra algunos
valores dados de la función
diferenciable efe y por aquí nos dan los
valores de esta función para algunos
valores de x en particular para 5
valores de x nos dicen cuál es su
correspondiente
efe de x y también nos dicen cuál es la
mejor estimación para f prima de 4 es
decir la derivada de nuestra función en
x igual a 4 o también podemos pensar
esto como la pendiente de la recta
tangente cuando x es igual a 4 entonces
cuál es la mejor estimación para f prima
de 4 que podemos hacer según la tabla
elige una respuesta así que pensemos un
poco en qué es lo que está pasando antes
de ver las opciones muy bien ahora
déjame dibujar no sé qué es por aquí y
déjame poner estos puntos
sabemos que estos puntos viven en la
curva que igual a efe de x así que si x
es igual a 0 efe
x es igual de 72 y por lo tanto tenemos
el punto aquí 0 72 el punto 395 el punto
5 112 el punto 6 77 el punto 9 54 y
claramente tenemos distintas escalas en
x 100 jeff es más déjeme poner los
números aquí en el eje x tengo uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
diez bien ahora lo que nos preguntan es
cuál es la derivada en x igual a 4 y al
menos tenemos el valor de f cuándo x es
igual a 4 no no conocemos ese punto pero
lo que podemos hacer es nuestra mejor
estimación ahora teniendo estos puntos
quiero que observes que no sabemos
exactamente cómo se ve la gráfica de f
podría verse como un montón de cosas no
sé podríamos tratar de encajar una curva
razonablemente suave como ésta
pero podría ser distinta una curva llena
de giros y vueltas algo así no sabemos
con exactitud lo único que sabemos es
que necesitamos pasar por estos puntos
porque la tabla nos dice que pasa por
estos puntos pero esta curva tiene
muchas vueltas y muchos giros así que
para mayor simplicidad de este ejercicio
vamos a suponer el primer caso que
tenemos una curva razonablemente suave
sin tantos giros ni vueltas algo así y
nos preguntan qué pasaría si x es igual
a 4 si esta curva de amarillo fuera tal
cual es entonces aquí tendríamos el
punto 4 coma efe de 4 y cuál sería la
pendiente de la recta tangente en ese
punto bueno lo podremos visualizar así
ahora para ser claros esta recta
tangente que acabo de dibujar es
solamente para esta versión de nuestra
función conectándome estos puntos pero
recuerda esta no tiene por qué ser la
función actual solo sabemos que la
función actual tiene que pasar por estos
puntos sólo estoy haciendo así para que
sea
fácil visualizarlo el punto aquí es usar
estos valores de mi tabla y hacer la
mejor estimación no sabemos si nuestra
estimación va a ser la mejor o incluso
va a ser una buena aproximación solo
serán lo mejor que podamos hacer
nosotros con la información que tenemos
en general cuando tenemos algunos datos
en un problema de este tipo lo que
seguramente nos piden es usar los puntos
que estén más cercanos al punto que nos
piden y encontrar con esos puntos la
pendiente de la recta secante entre esos
puntos y eso nos va a dar nuestra mejor
estimación para la pendiente de la recta
tangente así que cuáles son los puntos
más cercanos al punto 4 como efe de 4
bueno nos dan cuánto valen
efe cuando x vale 3 aquí lo tengo cuando
x vale 3
efe vale 95 entonces este declive es el
punto 395 y no sólo eso nos dicen
también cuánto vale f cuando equivale a
5 vale 112 y por eso tenemos aquí el
punto 5 coma ciento
así que lo que vamos a hacer es pensar
en cuál es la tasa de cambio promedio
entre estos dos puntos o la otra forma
de pensarlo es cuál es la pendiente de
la recta secante entre estos dos puntos
y esa será nuestra mejor estimación para
la pendiente de nuestra recta tangente
en x igual a 4 y sabemos si esa es
nuestra mejor estimación o sabremos si
estamos cerca del valor real
bueno no no podemos saberlo pero lo que
sí podemos saber es que con los datos
que nos dan esta es la mejor estimación
que podemos hacer esta aproximación es
mejor que la que podemos hacer si nos
tomamos la pendiente de la recta secante
entre x igual a 3 y exigua la 6 o entre
kuala 0 y escuela 9 o lo que sea esta es
la mejor aproximación porque estos son
los datos más cercanos que nos dan a 4
así que hagámoslo busquemos la tasa de
cambio promedio entre los puntos 395 y 5
112 así que podemos ver que nuestro
cambio en x bueno va de 3
esas cinco lo cual me da un cambio en x
de más dos de dos positivos ok y lo
podemos ver aquí y bueno cuando me x
incrementa en 2 mikel lo que va a hacer
es incrementar en cuanto bueno mi cambio
en quien es desde 95 hasta 112 lo cual
me da un cambio de bueno con 5 llegó a
100 5 + 12 es 17 17 también positivo
ok y lo podemos también dibujar por acá
observa este es mi cambio en que muy
bien que es de 17 y entonces ahora puedo
decir que me cambió en y
este con respecto al cambio en x déjame
ponerlo con su respectivo color al
cambio en x bueno esto va a ser igual
ahora ya lo sé me cambio en quién vale
17 entonces va a ser 17 ok esto dividido
entre el cambio en x que es 22 positivo
y bueno esto es lo mismo que 8.5 8.5 ok
eso quiere decir que si entonces mi
pendiente de esta recta de color verde
es de 8.5 esa va a ser nuestra mejor
estimación para la pendiente de la recta
tangente en x igual a 4 de la curva de
igual a fx así que déjame seleccionarlo
esta va a ser mi respuesta correcta
8.5 y para nuestra suerte si se
encuentran entre las posibles respuestas
y bueno quiero mencionar que no es
forzoso trazar la gráfica por aquí yo lo
hice para que tengamos una mejor
visualización del problema en general
cuando tengas una pregunta como ésta lo
que te están diciendo es mira no te
vamos a dar todos los datos que
necesitas para calcular exactamente el
valor de f prima de 4 pero si encuentras
puntos cercanos o alrededor de ese valor
entonces podemos estimar esta derivada
en x igual a 4 o dicho de otra manera
encontrar la tasa de cambio instantánea
cuando x es igual a 4 usando la
pendiente de la recta tangente entre los
puntos cercanos o lo que es lo mismo
encontrando la tasa de cambio promedio
entre estos dos puntos eso es todo por
este vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente